long may he reign long may he reign only
he don't may he reign long may he reign
all hail the new king and queen of
Westeros I think everyone just needs to
stop being so obsessed bloody right yeah
there's so much much this bloody story
here's everything you need to know about
the Game of Thrones series finale
with King's Landing conquered Daenerys
looked out transiently and declared that
this fight was only the beginning
pretty Noah Jana
[Music]
not wanting any more bloodshed Tyrion
decided his time as hand of the Queen
was over and Danny was quick to agree
Zhu teenager got those it ends
beautifully for my character whether it
be tragic or not
with Tyrion in jail awaiting his fate
john struggled to reason with Dany and
begged her to show mercy to the rest of
the people in King's Landing can't hide
behind small mercies
I asked the problem with the iron throne
no one knows she deserves it just as it
looked like John was ready to rule by
the side of his queen he did the
unthinkable
as if Danny's death wasn't shocking
enough drove on showed up to break our
heart and then he made a bold and fiery
this is something I thought about and I
think it would be really funny if she
just like got really close to the Iron
Throne and then exploded I think that
would be hilarious so they're gonna be
good with the Iron Throne destroyed the
series gave fans a time jump and
introduced us to the new council of
Westeros as the group tried to decide
who would be the new king or queen
Tyrion had his own suggestion do you
wear the crown why do you think I came
all this way I remember when I read the
final episode okay I got up and actually
genuinely had some pace around my flat
for there with his new small council
bran began to rule over the six kingdoms
of Westeros
as for the Starks Sansa took her place
as the Queen in the north I was just
numb when I read light in my last page
because it's just so sad it's so sad
that like that is the last time like I'm
reading my character you know and it's
just got to go on a long long walk
Arya sailed west of Westeros and John
was forced to take the black we've been
tethered by the show for a long time
we've loved it and now we get to enjoy
the final hurrah at least Game of
Thrones left us with the moment we've
all been waiting for
[Music]